welcome to leadership for society
reimagining work post covid i'm brian
lowery a professor at the stanford
graduate school of business and today
we're talking about the gig economy with
sam bright chief product and experience
officer at upwork
and melissa valentine professor at
stanford university in the management
science and engineering department and
co-director of the center for work
technology and organization thank you
both you for having us
grace i'm going to jump right in i'm
going to start with you melissa can you
define the good economy for us
yeah i think um so there are a lot of
different labels that are kind of
relevant to that but i i like the um i
like the definition that mary gray uses
she's a researcher at microsoft research
and she talks about any time that you're
using an api like it's like a software
call anytime you're using an api to
access labor
then you're participating in the gig
economy so labor accessed through an api
that's how i would define the gig
economy okay so labor access through a
certain type of technology you think
that that's what defines the gay economy
great so sam can you tell us about
upwork and how it intersects with the
gay economy
yeah so uh first of all thanks for
thanks for having us
uh when i think about upwork you know
we're a work marketplace that connects
businesses and highly skilled
independent talent many of whom are
entrepreneurs or small business owners
who are doing work on behalf of
individuals like you and i or all the
way up to
fortune 100 companies
and we provide
a solution for them to build
relationships between clients and
freelancers
we tend to view it as much more
relational and project oriented than
transactional relationships or
interactions
that are often the
associated with a gig economy uh such as
taking an uber ride or
having a handy a handyman or handy
person mounted tv
so from my perspective anything i think
upwork and the gig economy while
separate both fit under this like
broader umbrella of flexible work models
and so part of the differentiator is
that the jobs on our platform
have great pay they have high quality
work that's mission critical to
businesses
so we serve everyone from like i
mentioned from one person startups to 30
of the fortune 100 our clients including
you know like the airbnbs of the world
etc
and we find that clients
use
our platform to connect with different
freelancers
who are highly skilled can be developers
they can be you know engineering
freelancers to proactively execute
major business initiatives so i see them
as adjacent but separate
got it and how do you expect upwork to
evolve moving forward so the pandemic
has happened work is shifting in all
sorts of ways what do you think is going
to happen in terms of
upwork and its evolution in this new
space
yeah well i think if i take a step back
from from upwork i think it's just
taking a look at what's going on in
terms of society when it comes to work i
think work as a construct has been
disrupted
uh we went through this year and a half
experiment where many folks who had
traditionally believed that work could
only be done certain way
tied to certain previous
preconceptions of work
everyone was sheltering in place in many
cases in the knowledge economy and
managers had to adapt workers had to
adapt and i think it led to sort of a a
change and a re-evaluation in terms of
the perceptions on
what does work actually mean does it
need to be connected to a batch does it
need to be connected to a work location
does it need to be connected to a
commute so if we think about that
fundamental re-examination of work
within society then you think about as
the backdrop then you think about what
upwork is providing in terms of being a
place where work can get done
no matter where you are uh no matter you
know
we have like over 10 000 skills so multi
represented so like no matter what
particular skill you have
that gives us a lot of opportunity to
solve customer problems and to provide
the control and flexibility that
freelancers are looking for in terms of
being able to work however they want to
so i see as work continues to evolve
upward being at the forefront of that
and part of what we've been doing over
the past years we've transitioned from a
single product line company to a
multi-product line company is really
enabling
freelancers and clients to be able to
get work done however they see fit
as changing customer expectations are
evolving
our aspiration and our charge is to
really
lead that that charge and to
uh you know fulfill our our vision of
being the place where the world wants to
work
that's there's a lot going on there so
i'm gonna i'm gonna come back and ask
some questions about that but let me um
turn to you for a second melissa uh i
know you've done research on the gig
economy um how do you see the gig
economy now and where do you see it
going as a function of the pandemic
yeah i mean i think there's a lot that
connects in with what sam was just
saying i think that the pandemic
culturally made a lot more people aware
of the possibility of working remotely
um something that's characteristic of
work done on upwork and other platforms
like upwork is that a lot of it has been
done remotely so this is a way of life
it's a way of working that's more common
and that's more experienced for people
who work on platforms like upwork
so now that more companies have
experience with remote work and can kind
of see what it's like and how much they
can get done not in the office um it i
think that it sort of connects uh like
larger
kind of older like bureaucratic
organizations with
the kind of work that's done on a like
platform-based company like upwork um i
think that the difference and this is
something i would love to ask sam about
at some point
i think one thing that i think um
i think where there's like kind of a
middle area that hasn't been connected
yet is uh between
large companies
that have a lot of team-based work or a
lot of interdependent work we have a lot
of complex projects that involve a lot
of different functions and a lot of
different kind of expertise that's
brought together in larger projects
um so upwork traditionally has been more
of a market so it's more like even
though they're very high skilled
freelancers it's it's matching sort of
like client to freelancer and more of a
market design
my understanding is that that upwork is
moving into more team-based projects and
more and offering more project-based
work but i think that's um going to be
something that people who are interested
in the gig economy are going to be
watching for because there's there's so
much work there's so much high-value
work that's kind of right there in
between market
production and organizational production
if that makes sense and i guess i'm
seeing with with the pandemic i guess
i'm seeing that gap that sort of space
between closing faster
so i i'll let uh sam respond to that
question in a second but tell me why i
should i well i like i like remote work
so it's it's fine and it's also kind of
easy given what i do most the time i
have to teach i'm in person but
otherwise like when i do research i can
be wherever so it works for me
but
why shouldn't tell me why i shouldn't be
worried about the tyranny of remote work
so all the language is like oh it's
going to be great there's flexibility
but in that in that world there is
choice
but let's imagine that organizations
decide it's cheaper to have remote work
but i or someone people like someone
like me other people don't
aren't really excited about it right so
tell me why i shouldn't be worried about
this shift it had what like what are the
or
better yet what should i be worried
about when we think about this shift
um so
i think this is i mean it's such a great
question and this is what i'm seeing a
lot of organizations grapple with right
now
you end up with
the remote work enthusiasts and then the
remote work skeptics and somehow they
have to find a way to work together
i think what we're seeing is
compromise
doesn't really work because it sort of
reproduces what's hard about both
systems so if you
have a company that has a culture of
more remote work skeptics and you end up
going more remote and
to make to make more remote work work
you have to do a lot more documentation
a lot more like asynchronous
coordination and there's a lot of cost
to that so you really have to invest
heavily into that kind of work
um alternatively if you have people who
want a little bit of the flexibility but
are relying much more on like real time
collaboration then there's a whole other
set of coordination costs to get people
into the office at the same time
so i don't know that i've seen this kind
of solved and
solved in a way that really um
combines the two i'm seeing more sort of
like sorting people are sort of sorting
into like self-selecting into companies
that are
solving it one way or the other
and sam what what do you think about
that so i mean i know that you have a
wide range of people who are on your
platform so it's not just um low-wage
workers they're people who are
technically very savvy and skilled but
how should we think about how far this
is gonna go
right so would you have your job would
you do your job via this this form of
work
yeah so i i think the uh
um
i think a couple things i think first of
all
uh
there are many folks who probably never
considered remote work who during the
past year and a half realized that there
were benefits associated with
being able to
uh not have to deal with the commute or
be able to collaborate in different ways
for me personally i have an 18 month old
son and my son was was born at the
height of the pandemic and the
ability
to not be in a commute uh every day and
actually be there for him while he's
getting ready or to do our nighttime
routines is you know transformative in
in many regards uh so i do think you
have these folks who are
uh especially especially different
generations who are coming to work for
the first time uh during the moment
where remote work is more of an option
who are
more remote natives and so
just like digital natives who are folks
who are very comfortable with you know a
digital first organizations i think
we're gonna have more remote natives
um i also
joined upwork during a moment where
everything was done remotely so i did
the entire interview process i joined up
work in november i did the entire
interview process over
uh virtually uh
i hadn't met anyone on the leadership
team or on my own staff i was setting a
laptop and was like go off and do things
uh and so it was only subsequent
subsequently uh probably six months in
or so
when the pandemic started to get a bit
better and folks had had gotten
vaccinated we were able to rapidly test
that i was able to go and meet with uh
some of my my colleagues and be my boss
and meet other folks who were
uh who are on my team and it was kind of
a unique dynamic probably the only time
in my in my life thus far where people
who you've never met run up and give you
a big hug
because they've been you know
collaborating with you for uh for many
years or for not for many years but for
many months um
so so that's that's a really interesting
dynamic i think that's at play
as well
i think that remote works going to
continue to evolve and that
we're going to keep adapting you think
about all the different collaborative
tools that have emerged and that
continue to emerge as people are
learning how to get work done and how to
triage uh during these moments and i
also think that there's there's various
spaces on the continuum for for
companies right like you know for upwork
we're choosing to be remote first so
when our offices in san francisco and
chicago uh open next month uh we're
still gonna have those physical offices
and we're to give people options to go
into those offices as they see fit but
it's not going to be required i'll
probably go to the office you know every
every few weeks or so
and it'll create an opportunity for
those who are looking to collaborate in
person or have those sync points
to be able to engage but the the one
point i want to call out though is that
when we talk about remote work some of
it is really predicated around remote
from what because people have been
working in satellite offices have been
remote for the entire time it's just
that up until now
they've you know different leaders have
gone and met with them or they've been
able to fly back to company headquarters
i think certainly geographically
distributed companies or smbs who have
different locations
uh have always had folks who have been
quote unquote remote from headquarters
just now the question is how much do you
have to be proximate to an office versus
you can you know work from home as your
office and still be able to engage and
connect with co-workers along the way
and i also i want to draw a distinction
right between just pure remote work and
like gig work and gig we can also use
the term freelance right because there's
a flexibility that's certainly
associated with remote but there's also
flexibility and all challenges
associated with being freelance
so how do you think about the
costs and benefits of the freelance work
where they're not really connected to
the employer in the same kind of ongoing
you know contractual relationship that a
regular employee is how should we think
about
about that from your perspective sam
yeah so i think we've seen an increase
in folks who are interested in
freelancing
uh as part of the as part of the
pandemic i think that
you know we did some research around uh
a freelance ford report we found that 12
percent of the u.s workforce began
freelancing during the pandemic for the
first time uh nearly half of gen z
professionals are freelancing in some
capacity and about three-quarters of the
folks who have freelanced said they
wouldn't go back like you couldn't pay
them enough money like they love the
control
on average they have you know or the
median number of clients that a
freelancer has according to the
freelancing in america report that was
done in 2020 uh over a six month period
is six clients so
a lot of the freelancers you're right
there's like a delta between freelancing
and remote though obviously when folks
are remote i think they start to
question other assumptions about work
and are like well why not try
freelancing why not have the flexibility
of being full-time at some points being
full-time and moonlighting being
freelanced at some points and just kind
of you know evolving their careers as
they see fit
i think that um
i think you do see more and more uh
individuals willing to try out this mode
of work uh because of the control that
it gives them they don't have to put
their eggs in one basket they can
upskill at their own pace they can work
for multiple companies etc as as they go
along and freelancing doesn't have to be
someone something that someone chooses
permanently like there are people who
may decide to freelance for a time and
then you know become a full-time worker
again and then another time move into
freelancing again it's just another
option for folks to
to consider
and melissa you know the our economy is
built on the assumption of full-time
work with an employer right like not
just our economy but the way our lives
are set up socially right so healthcare
and other benefits when you think about
this move toward freelance what are the
concerns you have or what kind of
problems do you see arising and what we
need to do to make that viable
yeah i appreciate the distinction that
you're making there i think that um the
move to remote has remote top of mind
for a lot of us but i think the
questions the really important and
profound questions with the gig economy
have to do with the employment
relationship just like you're saying
so previously we have
structured so many of our benefits
around full-time employment in
organizations and the united states is a
little bit weird in that regard we have
health insurance and retire so many
things are structured around
um full-time employment
so now with um
i sort of i'll harken back to what i was
saying at the start with the with the
api as like a as a software call to
labor
um the reason that i want to
point to that because this is this is
bigger than upwork upwork is kind of
amazing for how long they've been um you
know
revenue positive like for how long and
for kind of how big they've gotten
but this uh the gig economy is is so
much bigger especially now with um
apis sort of connecting into lots of
other data
systems that have like large remote
workforces you can like have an api call
to
a pool of doctors so upwork has a lot of
you know software they have so many
different kinds of experts but you could
have it to doctors to lawyers to
accountants too um i i met some
mbas who graduated from harvard business
school and now they have like you can do
an api to get like a business plan so
there's so many different kind of labor
pools where you can have this call to
the large labor plan sort of like source
source a project on demand so it's that
kind of on-demand sourcing of um
high-value work that that is um kind of
driving the conversation now about the
employment relationship that we're
seeing so i've i've interacted with a
bunch of different companies that have
set up these models where you have some
sort of platform and then some sort of
large labor force
and
um those freelancers are
now
you know they have like the way that
their career trajectory looks is
different the way that their training
looks is different the way that their
social group looks is different so
there's so many differences in how this
kind of platform and network economy
looks compared to what we've had in the
past
oh go ahead i'm sorry i didn't mean to
interrupt i i was just going to agree
with you that i think that the social
safety net that has formed around
full-time employment is what people are
concerned about
and speaking of that i wanted to ask
about your thoughts on prop 22 if you
could explain a little bit about what
that was and how it played out that'd be
really useful
yeah so i want to uh i want to actually
just be clear that i'm not a policy
expert like a lot of my
research and expertise is on the
structuring of work in the gig economy
and in organizations so i'm hesitant to
sort of speak uh about the policy
implications of of these um i think the
lesson that we can kind of take from it
and sort of like what to walk away from
that question with
is that the
employment classification that we've
used in the past doesn't apply it's it's
very complicated to apply
the employment classification that we've
used for decades to what's going on
right now
let me just give one small example
that's actually not related to upwork or
uber but i think really highlights
what's in what's sort of at stake here
so this goes again to mary gray's
research she's written a book called
ghost work
she looks at mechanical turk amazon
mechanical turk which is another
platform that sort of sources to a large
labor pool
and
that labor pool is doing a lot of the
work that trains the data sets that
large corporations are using to train
their ai so ai products sort of depend
on the mechanical turk workforce
um that workforce is
less seen and less visible than uber or
upwork but they have sort of the same
issues of not necessarily having uh the
safety of like full-time employment
so mechanical turk
workers might come onto the platform and
work for a day and you know they'll do
uh like they'll label images for example
to train a data set
um so we don't have a classification we
don't have a way of understanding that
kind of employment in our country right
now so we don't have a way to protect
those workers um so what mary gray
suggests and i think this is right and i
think that prop 22 sort of relates to
this we need to rethink our employment
classification system in a really much
more fundamental way
and what does that look like so we're
reimagining i mean i won't obviously
hold you to it but what what is that
what are we what are we trying to
accomplish what's the goal and how do we
how would you suggest where we start
even thinking about it
yeah so so i really appreciate her um
remarks on this and i can uh i can share
some of the links to her writing on this
but she sort of rec she sort of argues
that what we need first is a cultural
change um a cultural change where we
recognize and make visible the kind of
labor that is powering the digital
economy right now um a lot of those
products sort of depend on the
invisibility of this kind of labor so
the more that we make visible and kind
of value the contributions of all the
people who are working then the more
that we understand the kind of
protections that they might need
to tie it to what i was saying about
employment classification
it's really hard to say if these are
self-employed people part-time employed
people full-time employed people
freelancers entrepreneurs it sort of
defies our historical understanding of
employment
so her argument is we need a culture
change uh she makes the analogy to child
labor laws like at some point society
was like well that's not something we
want to do we don't want to have child
labor laws so child labor so she
suggests that we first need a cultural
change where we are much better at
valuing all of the work that contributes
to uh the economy right now
um and then
based on that um
i don't so i
i don't know if i you said you're not
going to hold me to this her argument is
that um so i think one thing that we
should we're thinking about that we as a
society are thinking about is where the
benefits come from
and how they get attached is it from
companies is it from the government
things like that yeah because i guess
one of the questions i have is who's
benefiting right now from this shift
right is that benefit being shared
equally across different constituents so
consumers
people who are doing the work and then
the people who are managing or running
the organizations so do we think in your
in your from your perspective you think
those the benefits that we're generating
are being distributed equally across
those
those different categories
i think that's a really insightful point
i think that's a really good point um
i mean i would be going off intuition i
feel like it's an empirical question
that's really important and worth kind
of looking into my understanding of
where value accrues right now in a very
digital economy is sort of owners of
data get a lot of value
so the workers are tagging data and kind
of creating data sets that are then
owned by companies and kind of producing
really valuable data sets so i would i
would conjecture that a lot of the value
follows the data
and i'm curious sam about your your
perspective on this in terms of i'll
just focus on the power of the the
employees or i guess the workers how do
you see this way of working in the
freelance because for upwork it's mostly
freelance not not necessarily gig in the
way we think about uber or lyft
um but
how is this freelance style of work um
affecting worker power right in their in
their in their organ well not their
organizations and organizations they
engage with
yeah i think it's a great question i
think it's
i think it's redefining
access for work
i think we're seeing companies change
their mind from talent acquisition which
presumes that you own work our own
workers to tell an access which really
empowers workers to not just work with
you but work with multiple companies as
needed so i actually think that
it's a pretty important shift in terms
of providing more access
to that i think has the potential to be
much more equitable than prior modes of
working if you're not dependent on the
old old good old boys network if you're
not dependent on being two hours away
from a company headquarters if you're
not dependent on who you know or you
know a resume in some cases in order to
be able to work and and you know provide
for your family and provide for yourself
that creates a lot more opportunities i
think for
workers to not only get things done but
build their careers in ways that suit
their lives in a very different way and
be able to you know work to live as
opposed to live to work so
uh
now i i can't claim to be a policy
expert or speak on those points but i
can certainly say from a freelancing
perspective especially for highly
skilled knowledge work like what we
found is that the
many of the freelancers uh
uh choose to
um
like the choice that they that they're
afforded through being able to you know
participate in a freelancing uh
lifestyle and in some cases they
get access to companies that probably
wouldn't have considered them previously
uh or might not have brought them in uh
through being able to work with work
with those companies through a platform
such as ours
an interesting stat too
you know we
we're seeing how it impacts education as
well because
we we
survey freelancers periodically and
you know even though 81 of them say
their college education is useful to the
work they do now
of those with a four-year college degree
about two-thirds of them said that they
wish they had instead obtained a
two-year degree and supplemented their
education with online training so they
could focus on upskilling on the things
that were most interesting to them and
so it's just that it's just a paradigm i
think a paradigm shift i think the
social contract is being rewritten
and it's giving more power to to workers
uh to decide who and where and how many
companies they want to work with in ways
that we haven't experienced before so i
think that's pretty exciting and
probably has dni implications as well in
many real ways
and companies are still pretty powerful
though so i wonder what kind of
safeguards you build in for the people
that do freelance work at upwork like
how do they make sure their interests
are protected when they're working with
an organization
yeah so
companies
so freelancers can
apply to jobs
there's multiple ways to work right like
freelancers can apply to jobs that
clients have posted on the platform they
can actually
be invited to jobs the clients that post
it on the platform
and they can get you know uh
they can set their own their own hourly
rates how much they're willing to charge
and
uh your flat fix project uh fixed
project costs and kind of determine like
what you know companies are willing to
uh to hire them for
the skills that they are they are
producing uh we also have you know uh
project catalog which gives more project
oriented work so freelancers can
actually kind of you know have this
browse and buy
upfront pricing say i'm gonna design a
logo for x amount of
x amount of dollars and you get two
revisions and so while they're sleeping
someone can hire them uh to do that work
based on you know browsing their
portfolio and then we also have you know
uh talent scout which actually provides
betting of clients as well as vetting of
talent so that uh talent get that
flexibility in terms of understanding
the clients that they're working for so
uh we have a variety of and safety
features that we have put in place to
protect both sides of the marketplace uh
talent to make sure they're working with
good clients and then clients to make
sure they're working with uh great
talent and everyone's learning as as
they as they go uh so
i think it's really important that both
sides of the marketplace are invested in
and the flexibility for talent to be
able to work however much they want uh
with whoever they want to work for for
however long the duration of time that
they want to work with them is truly
unique when you think about work
as we traditionally thought of it
yeah and if i'm and i'm
someone who's on upwork and i have a
contract
and it goes really poorly like i'm i'm
treated poorly like what what is my
recourse like how do i how do i deal
with that if i have a really terrible
experience i feel like i'm being
mistreated
yeah so we have our
customer experience team um which
i have the
good fortune of getting to work with
quite closely who
you know there's there's paths to to you
know
file a case and say hey here are the
issues but also because a lot of the
work is done on our platform and we have
milestones we can actually check and see
hey you both agreed on you know this
work was good versus versus not and
allows us to be able to arbitrate in a
very uh fair way for for clients and
and talent alike uh we have time
trackers with variety of different
features
that uh protect both sides of the
marketplace and you know something goes
wrong then we're there to
help support and get to a speedy
resolution
and i'm going to go back to i think
melissa had a question for you so i'll
bring it back and then melissa can make
sure keep me honest about it um but
often we have you know complex teams and
organizations now and that seems like
it'd be difficult to put together in the
kind of freelance you know style of way
at least i understand or i'm envisioning
upwork so on the employer side if
they're using this model how do they
manage those complex integrated teams
yeah so
i guess there's a couple different
dimensions to that we have we have
enterprise
companies who use our use our platform
and they have talent clouds and
different pools of of workers who
collaborate with them to get different
needs addressed depending on the hiring
manager that there are
the particular needs of the hiring
manager right so if i'm at acme co i
might you know need a certain type of of
work done and i'll get a set of folks
then i'll add to my virtual talent bench
and i'll work with them over time and
some of them also uh you know who's in
another function will do the same thing
but then in addition to individual
freelancers we also have agencies on our
platform which are effectively uh
sometimes are completely independent in
other cases there are groups of
freelancers so sometimes we'll have
really successful freelancers on the
platform who decide they want to create
an agency and have multiple freelancers
who work with them and then clients will
engage with that agency uh and sometimes
to hire
individual freelancers or just source a
variety of freelancers from uh for a
more complex project and so that goes
back to my earlier point about this
being
in my view quite different from gig work
because in some cases these
projects are quite complex they're
expensive they're over a long time
duration people are working for you know
for months at a time uh to be able to
support the needs of their clients as
well but i think professor valentine is
right to nudge that
there will probably be
there is increasing demand
for
talent to not only find each other
within the upper community and to not
only be able to build their own agencies
but also
for potentially other ways to work to
evolve
so i think we're paying close attention
to uh what customers are
are telling us and we'll see where
things go from there
and melissa you um mentioned when you
were talking about gig work that upwork
is a little bit different because
they've been
profitable for a while they've been
doing they've been doing this for a long
time they have a certain amount of scale
but there are other gig companies that
are huge
um who have not been you know
profitable and been dependent upon vc
money to keep prices arguably arguably
artificial artificially low how do you
how do you think about those companies
going forward like what do you expect to
happen um when that when those prices
start to go up as in for example with
uber and lyft it appears they're
starting to go up a bit like do you
think that's viable long term
so i think um i mean
the
rideshare industry is is also kind of
like a pecu or a a specific
section of the gig economy so with um
with upwork
and so i was at when you were asking the
question i wasn't sure if you were
referring to um i've worked with
companies that are doing um things like
software development or
you know movie animation or things like
that um so i don't know that i actually
don't know that i can comment on
the the kind of uh industry
profitability for uber and lyft i don't
know if either of you have have can
comment on that i don't i don't know
that i can speak to the right healing
industry
yeah i guess i just wonder is the gig
economy in our current social context
is it viable that's kind of what i um so
we can we don't have to call it uber or
lyft but the gig economy because i would
say i'm going to separate upwork a
little bit right they're they're not in
the same kind of category as some of the
what i think most of us have direct
experience with and there's a variety of
ways that we engage with gig work a lot
of us
i'm wondering do you think
in the current social political space
um that the the way gig work is set up
is that it's in your mind is that viable
ah i see yeah yeah so i think um
i think there are different trends that
are pretending that this will be
like a larger a larger part of the
economy like a larger way of working um
i think that the gig economy is part of
it the gig economy as we currently
understand it where you have startups
that are creating platforms that connect
in with networks of laborers like labor
that's part of it
um but what i was describing before with
um
actually i can point to the research by
jerry davis who's a professor at
michigan and he has been his research
looks at the population of public
corporations in the united states over
time
and he's shown that
the number of public corporations in the
u.s is shrinking the number and like the
population and the size of public
corporations is just smaller
um he he gives an example of when
circuit city
in 2009 circuit city liquidated
they had i think it was like 30 000
employees and then
someone bought them and then they became
just a website so now they're just like
a website where you're fulfilling orders
for electronics so instead of having a
large
uh set of full-time employees now you
have like a website basically where
people are able to buy electronics and
what made that possible was an api
right so we have apis that are basically
connecting different parts of companies
you can now have an api to like
marketing you can have an api to like hr
and api to accounting so instead of
needing to have a large corporation that
has each of these functions you can now
sort of have this small lean
staff maybe that connects to different
um functions that you'll spin up from
time to time so i'm hearing a lot of
discussion about how there might be kind
of small core
to a company and then a lot of kind of
contingent labor of some sort in the
periphery around
i think that i think we're seeing that
that seems likely it's not a question of
whether it's profitable it's kind of
it's what's happening right now i think
i see and do you see that as
exacerbating inequality so you have like
this core of people who are in the
company and these and then the i don't
know i'll call it the periphery around
or the people who are who are contract
with around
do you imagine like let's say this is
you're out in the workforce do you want
to be the contractor do you want to be
central right exactly exactly that's a
great question
yeah i actually i have a story about
that um so my
a research collaboration team and i uh
did a study where we used upwork to
create flash teams we just like had a
platform that basically like pulled
together teams from upwork and they
worked together um it was published in
the new york times and we got a little
bit of attention for it and we were sort
of engaging with people on twitter about
it and somebody tagged me on it and they
were like if this is so great why are
you trying to get tenure at stanford
university
great question great question did you
respond
i mean i just i've told this story like
every day since then that's how i
respond it was it was such a loud
question it was really important it's
really an important question um
yeah and i think there's a lesson to be
drawn from it because what i love about
my job is actually everything that sam
was describing like i have so much
flexibility to pick my projects
and i have
like guaranteed pay of like lifelong
employment i have health insurance i
have benefits so i think people who are
working on the geek economy need like
we we all i guess society needs to be
careful about all the language that we
use about flexibility
when we're speaking from a place where
we have a lot of benefits kind of built
in around everything that we're doing
otherwise it is very likely to
exacerbate inequality as you're saying
yeah
and sam what do you think are the limits
of the kind of freelance work that
upwork supports right so it's i don't
assume that an organization is going to
become a fully freelancer i don't even
know what that would mean but fully
freelance um what what are the limits as
you see them for the kind of work that
upwork supports
yeah so
um i guess a couple thoughts i think
it's probably interesting to ponder
how the gig economy and the creator
economy are sort of
interfacing and uh if you think about a
lot of the entrepreneurs
on
the upper platform who are who are
freelancers like many of them are
creators and they see themselves with a
very
entrepreneurial then in terms of
delivering
products and services that then form
their their portfolios and then drive
additional work and higher dollars per
hour or higher fixed project prices i
think that's an interesting uh
an interesting sink point um but i'm
continuously surprised by not only
the breadth of skills that are on the
upper platform but then also
how many companies are
realizing areas that they thought may
not have been
able to
you know support hybrid work or support
freelancing that they find ways for that
to to occur so i expect we're going to
see more and more of that over time now
we're primarily focused on knowledge
work so
you know i think there are categories
where we are not you know present or
you know for whatever reason it's we're
not the right solution for for that but
we have people who hire get you know uh
higher paralegals we have folks who have
accountants and we have you know uh
see uh customer support uh team members
and you know you pick that pick the
arena we have people who provide music
lessons
through project project catalogs so
you pick the arena
knowledge work that can be done
virtually or even done virtually even if
the person on the other side of the
contract is your next door neighbor you
don't know it uh is something that you
know upwork uh supports and so
um
i'm gonna be really interested to see
how those vectors evolve over time but
it's going to be completely driven by
the demand that we see from workers
and as workers want to
have more flexibility in their lives and
don't want to go back into the office
and
drive two hours
uh each day to
laugh at jokes from their boss they
never thought were funny i think you'll
see more and more people uh choose
freelancing and categories that you know
we may not even be aware of right now
so okay here's an i'm still curious
about the limits so let's say i'm a ceo
i'm
our company is completely virtual
everybody is virtual why do i need a cto
or a chief product officer why am i just
freelance freelance people doing that
with that is that plaza is that possible
is that plausible would that be a good
idea from your perspective
yeah so i i have heard about companies
who are using uh fractional executives
for that very reason like sometimes they
will stand up organizations with you
know series of
c-suite leaders who will spend split
their time across you know three or four
different companies uh so you know
people are experimenting with that
even today how that evolve will evolve
over time and what the uh pros and cons
of that will be
uh i'm not sure i can speak to that but
i do think that
the general trend of us innovating with
work which has had this sort of like
really i think universally shared in
many respects like set of
characteristics
now that you know uh remote work is is
causing us to question things probably
makes us
really challenge whether or not some of
the assumptions we've had
across the board including that use case
are you know truly constraints
may i build on that brain of course yes
just another story i so i've given the
the flash teams talked to executive
audiences um for the past five years and
i think that their question is what
you're asking like what's the limit of
this so i'll present and i'll be like
flash teams you can like you know build
this like new team and it will help and
at the start everyone was like wow
that's so cool and then increasingly the
question that i get like starting three
years ago the question i started to get
was always like yes the problem the
problem is not access it's integration
the problem is always integration like i
think people are starting to like buy
into the idea that you can kind of
access a lot of talent quickly but
integrating what they build is like is
the real challenge at this point i think
so you think of that as a limit right
now
yeah
because i was wondering if all this is
making me think what is the corporate
structure we have or at least the way we
think about organizations is that are
you all suggesting that's outdated or
that we'll we're going to move beyond
that in the foreseeable future
i mean because sam that's what i what i
hear i hear you saying that is a a
distinct possibility and i'm curious
melissa and sam you can agree or not
agree with that i'm curious but melissa
do you what do you think about that
i this is the question
i'm glad that you proposed it like that
this is the question that i think about
and talk about with people all the time
um and i think we have like a classic
theory of the firm the reason that we
have organizations is because hierarchy
has just particular coordination
properties
it's easier to integrate there's a
little bit easier to have like
accountability and to integrate complex
work using hierarchy like that's that's
like classic economic theory right um so
i don't i haven't seen
anything that challenges that idea i
think how i think this idea of having
like a core and periphery is probably
where we're headed but having some sort
of firm at the center because it
coordinates complex work like that's
just a structure that coordinates
complex work differently
and there's actually a great paper by
some professors at mit that talk about
how accountability sort of accrues
within a hierarchy differently so
society sort of depends on be able to
point to something and be like that
company is accountable for this so
accountability and coordination are sort
of served by hierarchy
and that's what the firm does so i would
that's that's kind of what i'm thinking
about right now in terms of is how far
this will go
great and sam you have the last word on
that
well i i think that um
i think that
we've already seen
how work gets done in corporations
change quite a bit
uh folks who you know managed by
walking around or who were used to
facetime or what have you
all those things had to
had to evolve during the during the
pandemic and then people started to
adapt the way that they managed in very
different ways right like uh
weekly slack updates started to
and and virtual all hands and virtual
happy hours and you know zoom calls and
all sorts of different you know
dynamics started to come to bear
i think that there are parallel tracks
of innovation that are underway i think
folks are you know systematically trying
to build tools that will reinvent and
reinvigorate the workforce and in
parallel you have these trends of you
know the remote natives and remote work
underway that i think are going to
challenge these assumptions i do see i
do see a value for
the concept of a firm but i think how
that is constructed configured and even
you know
the worker composition of it over time
is we're going to be experimenting with
it i think as a society for a little
while and that's incredibly exciting
because this is a frontier of innovation
that i think we've um
i think there's there's probably been
less room for experimentation uh that is
is now being challenged
yeah well i i mean well i agree with
both of you that we clearly are going to
see a lot of experimentation and it's
going to be interesting to see how it
all evolves over time so thank you both
um very much for
talking with me today about it
thanks so much
all right so next week i'll discuss the
role of business philanthropy and
government to provide safety to the
people we'll talk to aisha
niandora ceo of springboards
opportunities and dr william spriggs
chief economist for the afl-cio
thanks you then
you